[Applause]
Denise Hey
so if knowledge is slow political can
you really be as neutral as you claim
actually I was I had a question for you
that I want to start with and we'll get
back to that one if they really if you
really want to do it have you ever used
a real paper encyclopedia yes I have are
you how old do you think I am
I'm checking do you think do you think
you're one of the last two to do that
quite likely yes it's been a while since
I consulted them one for actual for
actual knowledge although there there
are a lot of fun to to look at for a
window into historical ways of looking
at knowledge in fact on the last trip
out to the long our clock sight
alongside the stalks of toilet paper in
the Porta potty's we had copies of
Encyclopedia Britannica for us to peruse
during those moments is that how lovely
is that well I I mean I think was it a
choice thing that papers really thin I
could have looked at it that way and I
noticed that I think we had M's start
this the end of the m's
volume and a number of the mushroom
identification pages have been ripped
out for future reference but no I mean
it's a it's actually you know a
beautiful way of of coming to knowledge
which is entirely complimentary to to
the Wikipedia mode I think because
there's more room for the serendipitous
discovery of adjacency like in you know
the Dewey Decimal System when you're in
that section of the library and I think
we haven't quite figured out a way to
recover that that dimension of discovery
in the electronic realm well Ted Nelson
would say that doesn't matter right the
hyperlink is the whole thing but I know
what you're talking about
I love encyclopedias I actually you know
I actually read the Encyclopedia in my
house when I was a kid which was a
strange way to spend your childhood but
right there you have it and so it's kind
of funny that I'd end up at Wikipedia
given that
right but I was thinking when they were
talking about in a previous conversation
they were talking about the airship
thing I actually got an opportunity to
write on the airship have you been on on
it yet I have not no yeah so it's slow
right it takes forever but one of the
features of Wikipedia and in fact the
whole Internet is knowledge can now like
pour into your brain as fast as you can
consume it or maybe faster than you can
consume it right and there's some
evidence that at least the current
generation of humans aren't really wired
for that much information like people
get sick from it and and likewise from
flying too much and too much speed and
too much you know but I'm wondering
because I have three 24 year old kids
and they're wired different that sounds
like an interesting story yeah yeah
they're not but they're wired
differently you know they're in and I
think in the context of the existing
school system it's seen as a problem the
way they're wired right but I'm
wondering if it isn't an asset in the
long run well I mean I think when you
talk about how we're wired there's there
are a couple of layers to that at least
you know and and our plasticity is as
humans is absolutely extraordinary I
think I mean I particularly like a
comment that the Douglas Adams made want
you know the Hitchhiker's Guide author
who who said that anything invented
after you turn 15 is technology right so
before that it's just the air that you
breathe and up to a certain age you know
we sort of just accept the world in a
sense as we find it and adapt to that so
I mean I think there are there are
generational distinctions here but I
don't I don't think that it doesn't make
as much sense to me to say that we're
not wired for us for certain levels of
information I think we're we're perhaps
not educated for them and that that
schools are you know kind of catching on
kind of slowly universities even more
slowly to the to the reality of how
people actually like to consume their
information and their entertainment and
everything else but but i but i see
those changes sort of
as being possible for more possible from
generation to generation than within a
generation because you know after a
certain age it just gets harder we did
some surveys of who the people that
contribute to Wikipedia are and their
average is you know in their early 20s
they're white they're male they're
they're in some C s department somewhere
there you know is it was this across the
language well it's a problem we can
survey and I think there have been
surveys in other the other languages but
really the bulk of the editors are in
English and German and flesh but so that
told you that people who like to respond
to surveys are white and they're you
know but but when we go meet editors it
you know we see something slightly
different but not hugely different I had
this amazing meeting with we call her
the snail lady this woman that is a
mollusk specialist who's now a housewife
and she's spending all of her time be
like plumping up the mollusks in
Wikipedia you know right right because
and she's totally passionate about it
she actually told me she sees it as as
her legacy like this this is gonna
persist of all the things I've worked on
you know my thesis may be this this is
actually gonna persist
which I'm wondering is that why you got
involved in the clock something that
will persist not exactly I mean and and
I'm sort of right at the other end of it
from the engineering and I'm sort of
interested in the conversation like this
and all the other ones that spin off
from it which the the clock and all the
other long our projects are kind of
intended to engender but I so it's not
so much that I'm interested in a
personal legacy but that I see I see
value in this type of work and you know
want to sort of walk the talk in a sense
dude be as involved as I can be in those
things which I think are are urgently
needed and you know improving our
engagement with the longer term is
I think that is urgently needed even
though you know by its very nature part
of the problem is that we don't see the
reason for that or a lot of people don't
see the value of thinking longer term
but I wanted to ask you something that
you touched on in in your conversation
with Peter about the the difference
between wiki well that sounded like
there were three layers there's
Wikipedia or all the various Wikipedia's
in different languages the Wikimedia
Foundation which supports that and then
the movement that you referred to and
you've made that distinction between
Wikipedia as a as an artifact and
evolving artifact of knowledge and the
movement behind it can you say a little
bit more about about the movement and
what's going on there well it's
interesting because the movement is
trying to figure itself out right now I
mean to serve as we speak they're
working on a project called the movement
roles where they try to sort out
different people's jobs I mean it's
grown organically and of course some
people are natural leaders some people
have more influence or you know more
persuasive and over time certain
cultures have emerged if you will but
yeah it's interesting to me so the
foundation was not founded first right
that Wikipedia was a few years old when
the foundation button and it was created
as a as a you know vehicle to hold the
finances to keep them website running
because it's not cheap you know right
there's a amount of mail lists about
foundations and how they how to keep
them in because I've been involved in
open source for so long and there's a
million open source foundations and
they're giving to the place where not
everybody can raise money to keep their
foundation open so what do we do do we
like you know move them all together
because open source people are
fundamentally futurists too right they
they looked at the software industry and
went oh this is so broken and instead of
saying well you know I guess I'm gonna
spend my thirty years this way and then
I'm gonna you know do the next thing
they went we could change this and they
kind of roll their sleeves up and
started changing it right and now here
ten years on they've got this problem
they said well you don't have that
problem Denise because that you know you
guys make all your money from individual
donations and that's still true so for
some you know level of truth the
movement is the six hundred thousand
people who give us an average of $30
okay you know right I mean we're really
don't we're really actually funded that
way by individual people mostly by and
ly eighty percent of our money comes
that way which tells me that people who
use Wikipedia and find it useful want to
see it persist and they appreciate that
we don't have advertisement and blah
blah blah right but it doesn't end at
the boundaries of the of the donation of
donors does it I mean because it seems
to me that that that moved well if you
want to cordon it off there's that
movement and then there's all those
other open space initiatives that you
referred to I mean how do they relate
well oh you mean the open source stuff
well right yes sorry open source right
so open source as a set of rules that
say basically if I if I give you a gift
of my work that work could should
continue to be available to me forever
right that's basically what open source
says I should be able to reuse that work
because it's a gift in effect everybody
should be able to reuse that work right
so starting with source code which is
the easiest way to understand it I'm
writing this program and I'm gonna open
it and that means that if you come along
later and you find a way to fix it you
can and it's it's a better project
because anti-copyright
its anti-copyright that's well it's a
new form of coffee it uses copyright to
protect itself we called a copyleft okay
so so so people who read Wikipedia are
not often aware of that you know my mom
reads Wikipedia and and she doesn't know
much about the politics of that movement
but the people who donate the edits
they're very much those people they're
they're giving because it makes them
feel good to give and they're hopeful
that their donation of time and
knowledge is going to benefit the world
in a long run I mean they're pretty
pretty much always that you know
organized that way sometimes they want
to see their special subject covered
better because it needs better coverage
but or they or they believe it does but
fundamentally they're trying to give a
gift to the future right right and in a
way that it's reusable so that donor
community that I mentioned before
they're part of the readership right so
so six percent of the human population
the world reads Wikipedia every month
now according to pageviews and in the
next five years we're gonna try to
double that and when we say that we're
talking about reaching more people not
like sort of increasing our market share
but having more people get the benefit
of the knowledge and take some ownership
but one of our basic tenants because of
that open source thing when we take when
a new country starts a wiki they have to
show up and participate because
participation is ownership and one of
the things that the internet gives us is
all another opportunity to participate
so for the whole industrial revolution
we were sort of you know it's kept away
from the means of production right and
as consumers but now consumers are also
producers right right no and that's sort
of part of what I was getting at with
the question about the movement because
although your mother might not be
donating edits as a reader she is part
of a broader movement yeah you know that
vanity which which is you know
dismantling old
hierarchies and and infrastructures and
replacing them with new ones and I mean
that's that's the level which I find
this really fascinating and I thought
Ian slipped before and said open space
rather than open source is very
interesting yeah right right so open
space as a as an alternative way of
organizing conferences and conversations
in yo unconferences are another sort of
frame for it that you can which the open
source community kind of embraced right
thanks partly to Tim O'Reilly right but
we all just sort of drove right into
that and and yeah I met Stuart branded
in an unconference of course they did
right but this I mean sort of handing
the the resources to people so that they
can self structure their own inquiry and
their own conversations their own
learning is I think you know really kind
of fascinating and getting a lot a trend
of which wiki wikimedia Wikipedia and
and the donors and all of that movement
are a really important part
well people getting used to the idea
that the entitlement of the future is
the ability to participate it used to be
the ability to you know hang around and
wait for somebody to give you a gift and
when we go into the developing world
getting them to understand
that it this isn't a u.s. corporation
coming in for them to you know milk for
whatever we have to offer this is for
them to do something sometimes it's a
shift it takes a minute for them to get
you know right because there have been
so many waves of aid like the Peace
Corps stuff that we were talking about
earlier this is about no no really this
is yours it's only gonna be as good as
what you do with it
we don't write it well I want to take us
back to the governance question but a
slightly different angle Peter was
asking and you know the I wonder what
lessons there are in this work you're
involved in for how we might structure
our governing institutions you know for
governing society itself that's not
something that I've seen very much
commentary on but you must have some
thoughts on it
well it's an interesting question so
Wikipedia is you you get an immediate
reaction from your action you you edit
you can see you're at it but it may be
that just seconds later your edit will
get deleted in the current state of
Wikipedia deletion ISM is an interesting
trend in in the problem is we get so
many views and if there is some real
value to that and I mean a monetary
value to having your thing be on our
website for some second or two and so we
have a fair amount of spam people
because we offer the opportunity for
anonymous accounts to to do edits so
what ends up happening is people have
written BOTS that go through and scrub
new edits looking for likely spam right
and I think it's really disheartening to
new participants and I think if this
we're going to translate into a form of
government there'd have to be a check or
balance created that slows the process
enough that that the people's real you
know there isn't so much thrash
basically the thrash is very expensive
you know how when Obama was started
asking people good ideas what are your
good ideas and then remember what idea
was legalized pop man you know right and
that went right to the top of the list
yeah there you go
we live in California that's actually
gonna happen soon yay but it's not the
most pressing question right and and
that happens in Wikipedia too where
human nature sort of conspires to
sometimes create a false sense and the
thrash the amount of yes-no yes-no
yes-no that happens in people reverting
each other's edits and then reinforcing
them going back and forth is unfortunate
and I think would probably slow down
government at the end of the day we see
that now I mean we're seeing it right
now because we're about to have an
election in the form of dueling TV
commercials and radio commercials like
how much do you hate that right it turns
people after the whole process so
something would have to change there but
the idea that everybody gets an equal
opportunity to rise all the way to you
know some kind of custodial behavior
with a fairly low barrier to entry and
good good work being cumulatively
offering more meritocracy wouldn't be a
bad thing I think I mean that in the
example you've just given meritocracy
and democracy are in tension you know
because the more people you open open it
to the more thrash you get and the more
of that sort of chewing and throwing
mm-hmm isn't that the case yeah but then
you have to somebody's got to make the
tough decisions right and and how to get
those done I mean I even in my daily job
simple things like you know we're going
to create a new data center because we
need a better data center and there are
at least 500 people with opinions about
how we ought to do that but at the end
of the day I have to get it done and so
I have to make some decisions I'm not
sure how you balance that stuff now I
mean in in the bicameral Plus executive
by the way that we do things now you
know it's meant to create this thing
this checks and balance thing but it was
also done 200 years ago for a much
slower time and a much different way of
interacting now that we have the perfect
system you know but it's interesting
because yeah yeah nationalists in
America think that that this needs to go
everywhere in the world my experience of
being in the Peace Corps is they could
do without some some of our ideas
frankly you know particularly layered
onto their culture without a whole lot
of understand
where they live and who they are all
that stuff so I think there's some
potential there the tools are gonna have
to get better right and then we have the
problem of you know is the internet
gonna persist and can we can we trust it
I believe that we'll figure out how to
make the internet really bulletproof at
some point but we're gonna go through
some thrash first you know have any open
source advocates systematically
attempted to apply that thinking to put
to political governance actually the the
big place you see this is people wanting
the voting system to be open the code to
be visible so that so that there's less
opportunity for misuse and fraud and all
that stuff and there are a lot of people
working on that that I think it's unreal
and unlikely that that system won't
follow me what happens with open sources
there's some entrenched business
interest
it's an old business model where you see
this with music right right it's an old
business model the new wave washes
through and they're forced to the table
because it's so obvious to you know
casual people or users or somebody who
gets to make a vote with their feet
usually and then the old one falls and
the new thing is the way we do things
now that's that's like music downloads
right so so I think we don't have any
countries yet that are governed by open
source if that's what you mean I think
we're I just I'm not sure if voting goes
far enough we're still experimenting
with in the open source movement about
the ideal way to manage things there's
still very famous projects where
everybody's kind of mean to each other
what we're trying for generosity so it's
a good thing to try for thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you